do you know why people dump their
sisters
yeah
yeah
why
um
that's too much fun
you know it's like an ugly ugly sisters
it fits perfect you know it's like it's
Lego
you know what I mean so I learned about
this I gotta I gotta tell you I don't
know I gotta tell you about this so I
learned this I gotta tell you about it
right so there's something called the
Western Mark effect okay
what it seems like happens
um let's say that me and you are brother
and sister yeah I can't tell that you're
my genetic relative right there's no
um like little code on your face
you would be able to notice an affinity
but you wouldn't necessarily you're not
disgusted sexually disgusted because of
that the reason is because of this thing
called the Western Mark effect okay so
what happens is infants that are raised
together for a good amount of time
throughout their infancy usually between
the age of like one to two until uh like
puberty age yeah what they do is they
look at their parents and the family
around them and they see who is mum
giving attention to who am I being
raised with who's she breastfeeding if
you're the older sibling you look at um
did that baby like come out of mum and
around the time of labor was she holding
this baby that then became my brother or
sister and that's called the Western
Mark window right so you have this
period of time and what you get is this
sexual disgust imprinting so that's why
you don't have sex not because of some
inbuilt innate I know that you're my
brother or sister it's because of this
window now the interesting thing happens
when brother and sister are split apart
at Birth they'll [ __ ] not necessarily
but well I mean in the same like amount
of hit rate that two random people on
the street would do but they don't have
sexual disgust because they haven't
lived together for that time yeah same
thing goes for the father that leaves
the daughter's life and then comes back
in later in life and you think maybe
already daddy issues but also there's
something about this person it seems
like humans have a predisposition they
have an affinity toward people that
resemble them a little bit you actually
see you'll see them if you look at
couples walking down the street like you
kind of look alike a little bit and
there is an affinity for that so what
you end up with is this very dangerous
situation where two a brother and sister
have been taken apart and then come back
together and they don't have that sexual
disgust in Indonesia there was a period
where families would adopt the daughter
of another family when she was a newborn
and betrothed her to their son raised
them together but what they didn't
realize was that they were putting them
through this Western Mark window and it
meant that even though they weren't
genetically related they had sexual
disgusted yeah how interesting
so what would happen would they have sex
with one another with difficulty I mean
like brother and brothers and sisters
have done it before but it's [ __ ]
hard like it's very very ingrained yeah
to do that you should give them some
credit like for getting past it yeah
like a lot of Viagra and if good people
we tease all these like Southerners
they're like oh it's all incest blah
blah he's like brother or whatever like
that but like I guess what you're trying
to say is like we should honor them for
for their ability to break through the
Westmark barrier right is that what your
point is that's not if you bring this up
to justify incest I don't justify it
like more incest give them a medal
you're like like you couldn't your
sister your [ __ ] you know what I mean
let me but that guy did well I know that
you don't have a sister yeah and I'm an
only child so that you know of you could
have smashed out your sister in leads or
something like that he could have been
up in leads oh he separated at Birth she
had curly hair and a big jawline stupid
accent dude imagine adopted people got
to worry about all the time do you not
remember
um that sperm donor guy there was that
documentary on Netflix that dude that it
turned out he was the fertility doctor
and he was using his own sperm this is
in Brazil no he's in the U.S oh really
it's on Netflix now it's brilliant and
um this guy he like oh that's right yeah
like everybody and they were all
thinking that apparently one of the
women said exactly that which is like
waiting for the list of names to come
through and praying that it wasn't an
ex-boyfriend
but remember about that like she can we
also point this out like a lot of them
wouldn't have gotten like doctor
genetics
now I'm not saying they should be
grateful right but you know but like
they're probably objectively smarter
because of utility doctor yeah like I
mean is that not MD I don't know I don't
know maybe
it's bad what he did yeah but all those
kids are smarter imagine they're dumb
dads dude I mean fixing Plumbing all day
and [ __ ] like that coming home to this
smart ass kid right don't gym shark
don't cancel me yeah but like think
about it like they're smarter because of
it they were able to figure it out
because of that doctor Gene one of those
kids got to the bottom of it because of
the father because of the gift that the
father gave them yeah
so they done they did a study where they
got guys to imagine tongue kissing their
sister right you pulled the face so what
they were doing was they were videoing
the facial expressions of these guys I
was doing this because my sister would
also have a big nose so I was like just
getting out of the way it hits the mic
sometimes I've noticed yeah
um and uh they had they were tracking
the facial expressions and they can
um categorize them yeah they could say
this is disgust this is happiness it's
blah blah blah yeah yeah and they found
that right on cue some of the guys were
like oh and some of the dudes were so
far back that the camera went out with
Focus however the guys that didn't have
sisters showed a like a disproportionate
amount of like Smiles curling at the
edge of the mouth because it's like
there's no sexual there's no like
incestor version there's no sexual
disgust for that why do you think we're
so into like the stepsisters and that
kind of [ __ ] fascinating question I
don't know why like incest porn and
stepmom porn that's popping right now
isn't it the incest punch and the
stepmom porn well I think this the
military pandemic related like we're all
in the house together and it's like the
only person you're seeing is your
stepmom maybe there's definitely
something to do with the MILF thing
which is like an older more powerful
woman that can say what she wants I
think that's that's attractive I think
that's one of the reasons that guys go
toward the MILF thing I mean why do you
why why are people that's what guys are
turned on by that some guys are some
guys are turned on by like [ __ ] pawn and
all sorts of stuff yeah what do you
think about that that [ __ ] thing is so
odd I really can't oh yeah we were
talking about that though yeah I really
can't come up with a good example or a
good a good explanation for it I've got
a guy coming on next year who's one of
the Premier researchers into cooking um
so I'm going to ask him and I'll find
out like what it is that he's the
premiere one of them there's not many
imagine being like the worst like yeah
I'm one of the worst researchers in
cockporn like listen I watched my wife
get [ __ ] a lot like I've been no idea
why it's happening yeah I just can't
figure out why I love it so much
that's a premier researcher has he tried
it is it like some kingsy or like yeah
he's doing it for himself I have no idea
I don't know man but I mean what we're
saying out there is the the you're
trying to control an uncontrollable
situation right like you're getting
cheated on a lot so you're like okay I'm
just gonna allow this as if you're in
charge but being in the room and
watching it as a way to like almost
desensitize yourself yeah I don't know
dude I have a friend who uh was trying
non-monogamy for the first time and his
wife was upstairs banging her boyfriend
while he was downstairs stays dry
wretching on all fours on the bathroom
like bathroom counter and his driving
what is that oh throwing up like had
nothing to bring up but just she was
also up there like
like isn't that interesting that like
she was on all fours also dry wretching
in in unison together it's like we're
still together
um and he said he justified this is fun
mate
in other news this episode is brought to
you by whoop it is the best fitness
tracker that I have ever found it's the
only one that I've ever stuck with and
it tracks absolutely everything from my
sleep to my recovery even the workouts
that I do every single day through this
strap which is on 24 7. my resting heart
rate my heart rate variability and even
how much I'm breathing throughout the
night tells me my quality of sleep it
gives me trends and reports over time
but the most important thing is it
actually nudges my behavior through
suggestions in an app it's a digital
coach not just a fitness tracker and it
encourages me to change my behavior that
will improve my health over the long
term even better than that you can join
for free paint nothing for the brand new
whoop 4.0 strap and get your first month
for free so you buy it for free try it
for free and if you do not like it after
29 days they'll give you your money back
head to join.woop.com Modern wisdom to
sign up right now that's
join.woop.com
modern wisdom what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]